Michel Barnier
briefed the ministers about the state of
play in the brexit negotiations we
discussed the current status with regard
to the with all agreement as well as
with regard to work on the framework for
the future relationship with UK I think
we can say that little bit over 80
percent agreed upon on the withdrawal
agreement the upcoming informal meeting
insights we will have a discussion on
brexit which aims to reaffirm the EU
negotiation position especially in
Northern Ireland and to specify the
nature and degree of the detail of the
political declaration menudo vous pouvez
Alcoa Nicasio disappear important
governance Jericho appear to a monadic
as usual avec Akram operational event
with paid renewable back seat not
prepared to a peculiar impact that water
poverty and electoral key
satis say Randy Castillo JA graphic
novel demacia vas a meta no decisive
Soraka strong yellow days what we need
in the wisdom agreement is a legally
operational backstop which fully respect
the territorial integrity of the UK this
backstop will only apply unless and
until a better solution is found in the
context our future relationship